tres presidentes estadounidenses en un
mismo estado un hecho llamativo en la
campaña electoral de medio término que
determinará la mayoría en el congreso de
Estados Unidos el presidente demócrata
Joey Don afirmó que estaba en juego una
agenda aún mayor con esta votación
citando el creciente apoyo de los
republicanos de Trump a las teorías de
la conspiración la democracia está
literalmente en la boleta electoral Este
es un momento decisivo para la nación y
todos Debemos hablar con una sola voz
independientemente de nuestro partido
el actual mandatario estaba acompañado
del ex presidente Barack Obama para
respaldar al John federman un apoyo
importante para este candidato que se
enfrenta a reto añadido de recuperarse
de un grave problema de salud como ya he
dicho tuve un derrame cerebral y
realmente me golpeó en la espalda
pero me he vuelto a levantar
La balanza de Pensilvania ha conocido
como un estado péndulo se mueve Entre él
y el de la República no memes en cuanto
a los gobernadores el candidato
republicano es dogmas triano el fracaso
no es una opción tenemos que ganar el
futuro de nuestros hijos y nuestra
libertad está en juego recibió el apoyo
de la expresidente quien llamó a su
seguidores acudir a las urnas para
provocar una ola Roja en referencia al
color tradicional del partido
republicano
se apoyan la decadencia y caída de
América entonces deben votar por los
demócratas de izquierda radical si
quieren detener la destrucción de
nuestro país y salvar el sueño americano
entonces Este martes deben votar por los
republicanos en una gigantesca o la roja
Pensilvania se considera una victoria
obligada para el control del senado pero
también pesa en el equilibrio de poder
entre los 50 gobernadores del país cuyas
decisiones afectan a la mayoría de los
aspectos de la vida de los votantes
desde la educación y la sanidad hasta el
derecho al voto